[Music]
let's go to michael in philadelphia hey
michael what's up man
hey dr john how are you today i'm
you clearly see i'm still trying to
figure out how to use this phone so
sorry for hanging up on you just now i'm
an idiot that's okay i'll get it yeah
you'll get used to it i know right you
think
how about it hey so what's up man how
can i help
okay um
i'll give you the short story and you
take it from there um
basically what i have is uh my wife and
i are 57 years old
we started dating about four years ago
and about a year ago
she moved in with me
and we got married last september
now
since she moved in with me a year ago
she let her son who's 23 years old
move into her home
we both had our own home she moved into
mine and she let her son move into her
home now her son
is a hoarder
and
we're now dealing with
a year later with
we have junk cars all over the lawn we
have car parts all over her property
the inside of the house is a mess
and
[Music]
my instinct is to tell her
give them uh give them an ultimatum or
give them a deadline say hey you need to
buy such and such a date you got to get
rid of this stuff
or else
and she's got a very difficult time
doing that with him
and i'm having a difficult time
with her difficulty
yeah because
you know i don't want to overstep my
bounds in a sense of you know me
stepping in and
dictating things to him you know i'm
trying to do it through her
so are you
did y'all sign a prenup of any sort how
have you divided up your finances
well since we got married and i've been
a a dave ramsey baby stepper for the
last five years so we've basically
combined all of our our all of our
finances and everything is together
and uh so the reason i'm asking is is
at the beginning of this call you were
talking about your house and her house
and i know it's different when you're
getting married at 57 it can feel
different but
it would sound like when you get married
it's your house and you're in y'all's
house in y'all's house
correct and that's the way we're that's
the way we're treating it
for the sake of this discussion i just
want to let you know we both had our
separate homes you know right now as far
as i'm concerned what's mine is hers and
was hers there you go okay so yeah
do you need this house i mean is it
gonna help pay the bills is it part of a
retirement plan
it is part of a retirement plan okay um
we we um are in the process of planning
our retirement and
we will need that home and my home
uh
to be able to to to do what we want to
do in retirement okay
so
a couple of things to think through and
i know you know these things i'm just
going to say them out loud just for both
of us okay
the first thing is the 23 year old son
this didn't just crop up
when he was 22.
so my guess is there's a dynamic between
the two of them and any other family
members
his his biological father etc that has
led to
some sort of
traumatic childhood or challenges that
have led to this moment some sort of
interaction is that fair
yes okay
and
often did he have a rough childhood
he did okay he did he didn't he
primarily didn't have a father figure in
his life okay um his father
although he's been in contact with his
son
was
not really a um for the lack of a better
term but disciplinarian okay as far as
is in his in his upbringing and so does
your wife does his mom have a hard time
is she still living out of i'm gonna
make it up to you
she's a hard time holding him
accountable
i i i yeah i think par i think that is
part of it yes okay yes all right so
ultimately here i think we start with
you and your wife
because
this is sounds like it's the first big
test of your new marriage but y'all are
on way different pages here and i may
i know there's some uh
there's some uh what do you call it
there's some translation issues between
some of my best friends on planet earth
are from the philadelphia area and we
used to laugh about the translation
issues between texas and philadelphia
but
i can pick up
i feel like i'm picking up tell me if
i'm wrong i'm picking up
you are starting to look at her a little
bit differently like how are you gonna
let somebody do this to your stuff and
she says well it's just my son
and now this is
is leaving being about some guys trash
in your house to
oh man who did i marry
am i right or wrong tell me i'm wrong
um to a degree but i i wouldn't i
wouldn't i here here's my frustration
comes with her
um
being
i guess the best way to put this is that
i you know my what i say to her every
once in a while is that this because i
have i also have two 23 year olds also i
have two i have twins that are 23 years
old
and i at one point made the mistake of
saying well i wouldn't let my kids do
that no don't say that and i i know i
know i know i know
you learned about it you learned you
said you're sorry it's good
no yeah i did and and i also know that
um you know he's also been diagnosed
with you know adhd and
you know she has uh she's been diagnosed
with with depression and so i try to
i look at first i was like you know what
the hell is going why are you letting
him do this to now i kind of sit back
and i kind of try to talk it out with
her and say well what kind of
what
how are we going to handle this how are
we going to what are we going to do
i mean obviously you can't just say
we're going to kick you out of your you
know we're going to kick you out of the
house but
so hey what i'm telling you my father
would do to me michael that's that's
exactly what has to happen
and
adhd
is not an excuse to trash somebody's
home
right adhd is not an excuse or ocd or a
clinical hoarder um
that's not an excuse to
destroy somebody's property or to not
take care of yourself or to not be
hygienic or whatever the struggles and
challenges that are happening
those are a context
that is a
that is um
a way you lean it's a way that your body
naturally responds to certain things
whether it's environmental or it's
um genetic well it's actually it's a
combination of both those but there's
there's a bunch of reasons
so i want you to keep in your in your
mind both and
yes my wife is is has a tendency to run
low
she's had a ch like man she got left the
guy was a jerk whatever she's had
struggles for who knows how long
right she struggles with depression and
she's got to set up an environment where
she can be successful financially or
she's gonna have food to eat where she
can
help her kids be accountable she can
take care of her family
and so and same with him he's got
struggles of all sorts no no question
about that
and
he's got to have a situation that holds
him accountable
and he's got to have a situation where
people care about him and love about him
but aren't going to enable him to
destroy something because here's the
thing he's just going to go to the next
thing and he's going to go to the next
thing and he's going to go to the next
thing
so right and and yeah
so the question i think between you and
your wife is
i know that you
let me i'm thinking about me and my wife
um if somebody came in and said
somebody
yelled and screamed a grown up yelled
and screamed at our daughter who's six
in the parking lot and
um it's the parent of one of her
classmates
my
tendency to respond
my i mean my default setting in that
situation
i'm probably gonna go to jail right
i'm not gonna handle that well she on
the other hand my wife would be able to
handle that differently and i say be
able to i could be able to understand my
my tendency
and so
she would say i'm gonna have this
conversation first
and i would exhale really deeply and say
that's probably wise
and then in a week or so or a couple of
days you see what i'm saying so i want
you to stay on your wife and say
the reality is we have to have this
house
the reality is what's work what's what
we're allowing to happen right now with
our son
uh with our home is not working so we
all can agree that something different
has to happen
honey i have heard you that you can't be
the one that makes this call
right can i have permission can i have
permission to make this call
i will sit with you on your side of the
table when we have a hard conversation
with your son i will you you get what
i'm saying
i want you to say that's what i'm
looking for how can i support you as we
have to do what we have to do
because with someone struggling with
depression she knows
that he's got to get help she knows that
she can't let him just trash the house
and the fact that she's not
i must say can't um can't act on that
makes the depression worse right it
makes that shame spiral deeper and
deeper and deeper yeah it could be that
she writes a letter it could be that she
any number of ways but i want you to
reach out to her and say okay we all
know this has to happen
and also i don't want to put more
pressure on you than you're capable of
carrying right now i'm your husband i
agreed to partner up with this deal
what can i do
and then lean into and you maybe have to
be the bad guy in this thing and you may
kick him out and she blames you for it
and that's where you and her and the
marriage counselor work she has she
already done that
well she she has but then you know he
doesn't do anything and kind of falls on
deaf ears and he doesn't really
you know um okay mom okay mom i'll start
cleaning everything up and i'll start
getting things taken care of
and then you know a week goes by in two
weeks goes by and you know a month goes
by and the conditions are still the same
and nothing's changed and
so take him out of the equation
take him out of the equation if you had
to just a renter would you let him
destroy your home like this
well no i've i no of course not
absolutely not no chance yeah so
struggles and challenges are not excuses
to
destroy
so in supporting her in in you know
coming to some sort of a
[Music]
solution to this i mean is
it is this coming down to an ultimatum
like hey you've got until you know such
and such a date to have this taken care
of or
we're going to be forced to
do something we don't necessarily and
it's something we don't want to have to
do so i would sit with him and say you
son hold all the cards
anything that happens after this point
is something that you are choosing
i have drawn the boundary i have decided
that i'm not gonna have anybody trash my
home
i've decided that i've looked at the
math and i need this home your mom and i
need this home to be able to eat when
we're older
everything else you're gonna choose
you're gonna choose how long you're
gonna live in this house you're gonna
choose to um
whether the police come and escort you
out of here and all of this stuff is
thrown in the dump
you get to choose all of these things
but here's what it's going to happen by
this date everything will be cleaned out
of the yard period full stop
or i'm sending the sheriff over we're
going to evict you
or you'll start you can't do that it'd
be 30 days and plus another 30 days so
you have to sign the eviction papers but
you hear what i'm saying and when it's
like you're kicking me out no young man
you chose to not have live in this
particular house because you chose to
keep everything out there
even if taking that sort of stance
before too you know like right away he
tries to turn it around like it's our
fault that we're
coming down on him yep no
and hey i would stop that nonsense in
the middle of the conversation
like well you guys just stop
we're only working forward
today
so effective today this house gets
cleaned up
and i'll pay for three months of mental
health care for you if you need to go
see a counselor
i will
i don't know i'll get a group of buddies
from work and help load up the
junk in one of those day trailers or i
mean those you know those portable
i don't know they're those big
metal pod things yeah right you know
and i've and i've suggested all those
things you just mentioned and and i have
but what you haven't done you haven't
though put it put a or what
and yes we are at ultimatum time
okay
cause michael here's what's next you
know what's next your marriage
oh i i i agree i agree i mean it hasn't
really put too much of a toll on that's
coming yet it's coming like i
i know i see the clouds coming yeah it's
coming and
man i don't want that for you i don't
want that for your wife i don't want
that for this 23 year old
yeah and i'm trying really hard and i
know you are brother i also don't want
to and i also don't want to paint him as
like you know like like some kind of a
he's a really good kid of course he's
trying to take away from what he's doing
he's struggling you know i mean yeah
he's i mean he'd do anything for anybody
if i mentioned i needed a shed in my
backyard he'd be there the next day you
know with tools and building me a shed
in my backyard but when he should be
doing taking care of that well and the
one person he can't care for is him
no one's ever showed him what that looks
like
yes yes and this may be the first time
somebody says here's what care and love
looks like and it's holding firm
boundaries holding you accountable and
for the first time when i tell you and
you need to say this in a good
philadelphia accent
[Laughter]
a bunch of people in his life have said
hey man you got to do this or else and
they haven't held true and he needs to
walk away probably you know what put it
in writing put it in writing and hand it
to him he needs to walk away from the
table
understanding if this doesn't happen
this guy's serious
my mom is serious
all of this though brother starts with
y'all too having a conversation you and
your wife
going out and saying what's our what's
our what's our or what moment
what is our
plan and how can i support and love you
this is your son
but it's our home
how can i support and love you i'll be
the bad guy i'll have the conversation i
will lay out the plan i'll type it
whatever you need to do
but this has got to happen it's got to
happen